muchos turcos están muy enfadados con un
gobierno que creen que ha respondido
bastante lento a una situación que
probablemente ningún gobierno puede
responder como este vídeo de un
terremoto de tanda de tal magnitud con
tantos miles de edificios destruidos sin
embargo muchos se quejan que esta ayuda
hoy mismo 80 horas después de ese
terremoto del lunes por la noche no ha
llegado muchos lugares sobre todo en
pueblos de mediano y pequeño tamaño en
ciudades como esta ahora mismo estamos
en adana y aquí uno de los sitios mejor
conectados de todas las regiones
afectadas los trabajos aún continúan Y
no van a parar hasta que no se
encuentren a las más de probablemente
cientos incluso miles de personas que
están atrapadas aún bajo las ruinas de
todos los edificios de ruidos son casi
más de 5000 en todo el sudeste de
Turquía muchos de los de los miembros de
los equipos de rescate aquí presentes en
este y en otros lugares nos cuentan que
las primeras 72 horas son cruciales para
encontrar a alguien con vida a medida
que pasan estas horas la probabilidad
encontrar a alguien con pie debajo de
esas cada vez menor ahora ya creen y
aseguran que encuentran y lo vemos
Nosotros estando aquí parados mirando
Cómo funcionan estas obras que la
mayoría la inmensa mayoría de personas y
de animales también animales domésticos
que sacan de debajo de los escombros son
ya a personas que han fallecido